hello again now he said he'd gone into
semi-retirement from politics but Nigel
Raj is back leading a brand-new party
and he joins us now thanks very much for
being on the program and it feels like
to start with those local election
results of course a brexit party wasn't
standing and but it seems like the
conclusion drawn by both labour and the
Conservatives is that the public want
them to do a deal what do you think
would be the consequence I don't agree
about what the public want is to leave
the European Union you know we were
promised we'd leave on the 29th of March
500 MPs voted for it the Prime Minister
told is over 100 times we were leaving
on that date the public don't want a
deal and certainly not the deal that
mrs. Mays talking about this morning no
permanent customs union alignment with
single market rules the public want to
leave and for us to get on with the rest
of that watching our lives what do you
think the consequences would be if
Therese may enter Amy Corbin did push
forward some kind of customs union oh I
think if they push forward with this it
will be seen as a coalition of
politicians against the people and I
think millions of people would give up
on both labour and the Conservatives I
really do so it could be almost like a
realignment this would be the final
betrayal of it frankly if Bayside's up
to this I can't see the point of the
Conservative Party even existing you
know what's it for I mean you've got
you're using some quite loaded language
hit a final betrayal and your stools
they're talking about what the public
want me but the problem with this isn't
it is that people want different things
there are clearly some people who
support your party well we'd like us to
leave with no diff univers also a lot of
people who would like to see a deal or
perhaps even to remain in the EU in the
last two months there's been a
remarkable shift in polling in this
country you know leaving on WTO terms
with no deal is now the most popular
option but it's not a majority is it oh
if you offer people the choice it should
we stay and have a second referendum or
leave on WTO terms w here terms has a
majority but they're not the only toy
every single region of in London well
they are either we stay and we leave and
that's really what it's all about and I
honestly think if Mae and Corbin put
together a deal where we leave in name
only but we're stuck inside all the
European Union structures then I think
the realignment the British politics
will happen II
more quickly I genuinely believe that
sw1 the Westminster bubble not just the
politicians of much the comment area to
under estimating the desire for change
out there in this country let's look at
some of the polling shall we you of
course didn't stand as we said in the
local elections but have to say the
bricks that party is looking as if it is
going to do extremely well in the
European election so this is the latest
polling from you gov you're up there on
30% I mean how are you expecting to
happen well I think that we've clearly
done very very well as a very new party
we've done well with the UK though
that's almost disappeared we've done
well with a conservative vote I think
the significance of what you saw on
Thursday will be good I want two people
down let me just finish finish the
significance of Thursday night as we saw
the first cracks in the Labour vote you
know the Labour parliamentary party are
very very remain lots of them pushing
for a second referendum and to remain
but there are five million voters out
there labour voters who voted leave
particularly in the Midlands the North
and South Wales and I'd love between now
and polling there to have a debate with
Jeremy Corbyn about this because people
are very confused as to what Labour
standing for that challenge what it is a
Chafee what it is a challenge absolutely
I think if we can dig in if we can dig
in to the Labour vote that we can
surprise even ourselves how well we do
on May 23rd that polling was not looking
very good for new cake was actually
mentioned down on 4% yeah when you see
that do you think of SAS or do you
actually feel frequently 26 years of my
life I was with Yuki if I was the leader
the chairman the national organizer you
know for me leaving you kit was a
difficult thing to do but now frankly
it's past his sell-by date it serves no
purpose it's done it's gone I mean Tommy
Robinson is an advisor to UK yeah one of
its MEP candidates of you has used the N
word other offensive language yeah I
mean how would you define racism oh well
in in in the case of that particular
candidate it's just outright abuse you
know offensive abuse and there's no
doubt they've got a matter
action frankly you know we won't even be
discussing them after this is you could
a racist party well risk I think that
it's attracted certain individuals that
I would never have allowed join UK okay
well now let's talk about the brexit
party shall we
who's funding you amazing so he just
yesterday we hit 85,000 yesterday
registered supporters all paying twenty
five pounds
work it out we've raised getting on for
two million pounds through individual
people joining through our website um
and I can't think that any other party
in the UK's ever raise money like that
even said an interview previously that
you've received one big donation oh oh
yes I'm really gonna tell you his name
are not because of you because then you
would all hound him this is the new
transparent politics and yeah I will be
declaring it at the end of July so just
tell me that I don't see why I I don't
see one individual well I said he what
if everybody else will that's fine but
you know what'll happen if I took at the
name of this person you will hound him
all of you you'll be outside his house
for the next three weeks so no and
anyway it's irrelevant it's a small
donation it's a small donation of one
hundred thousand pounds we've raised I
repeat
maybe two million pounds in twenty five
pounds from individual assessment
scrutiny and you'll get it and he'll get
it all in good time who's funding change
UK well well there you are there you go
I also want to ask you about Claire Fox
as well yeah one of your candidates at
the top of your list in the northwest
and now of course there has been some
media attention on the fact that she
hasn't disavowed and some of these
comments that were made in nineteen
ninety-three defending this is a classic
stitch-up smear story number one she
made no comments herself in 1933 but she
was a member of a left-wing organization
who were Irish Republicans nothing
unusual in that and what they said the
Revolutionary Communist Party of which
she was a member they said we defend the
right to the Irish people to take
whatever measures are necessary in their
struggle for freedom I mean that was
made I think we may be looking at
Warrington let's just be very clear she
we Claire Fox says there were dreadful
things that happened before the peace
agreement which which which which she
hates the fact that they occurred she
supports the Good Friday Agreement and
does not want politics to be perceived
by violent means and the irony of being
attacked of her being attacked
when Jeremy Corbyn
John McDonnell were personal friends of
shin fain IRA personal friends /
attended Palestinian master ceremonies
you know commemorating people who
tortured and murdered Israeli athletes
you know frankly Claire fought frankly
this is a relevant college Amy Corbin
has said he has spoken to all sides in
the debate I have also asked her in
Corbin about his you know relationship
with the IRA in previous interviews I
think it's fair to say that he knew I
was a beginners very very well
absolutely and now I also want to ask
you about some points that you have made
and quite recently as well this was at
the Lock Haven University in the United
States and you were talking about
immigration and integration and you said
about this I could take you to a town
called Oldham in the north of England
where literally on one side of the
streets where everybody is white and on
the other side of the street everybody
is black yeah there is no assimilation
yeah well sadly true I was first put
onto this by Charles wheeler the late
respected journalist who Tony Blair
commissioned him to do a report as to
what had happened in Oldham why they've
been riots and this is pretty much what
he told me well and then and then in
Oldham Council themselves having looked
at the 2011 census so we have a massive
problem here of division I can even go
to the Guardians northern correspondent
Helen pin and if you look at it you've
got one Ward in Oldham that is 97
percent white and literally adjoining it
the next Ward that is 66 percent black
there is a massive yes because if you
know however however some streets
percent of population is back yes well I
tell you what let's go this week should
we and I will show you and I will show
you there is complete segregation with
all you're arguing for segregation
that's fine
I'm arguing for integration can't
there's a real problem I'm actually not
talking necessarily about integration
because there is a complex debate on
them what I'm talking about is the
specifics of facts because 1.2 percent
the population in all don't is black so
I just watched should we just try this
again should we just try this again
in one of the wards and Oldham it is 97
percent white and the adjoining Ward is
66 percent black they
you can believe me or disbelieve me but
they are the facts and I'm making an
argument here for integration what's
wrong with that
okay what's the brexit party's policy on
immigration we want a sensible
immigration of what we don't
discriminate against people that come
from India Australia and the rest of the
world okay now just finally who do you
think should be the next concept a party
leader I'm not sure that debates really
relevant uh I mean I know people to have
Boris or Dominic Rob well both of them
voted for Teresa mais treaty in the
final analysis I'm not sure either of
them really would deliver a proper
brexit Steve I think it was a different
conversation coming here I think maybe
the Conservative Party as it is isn't
really fit for purpose maybe we're
thinking really here now about a
complete realignment of British politics
the two-party system does not work they
serve no one but themselves and I
believe if ever there was a moment when
that two-party structure would break
down and be replaced by something new
it's now and that's what we're in the
brexit party I'm gonna try and do okay
ambitious I agree so far thank you for
your program